Freak bitches,
sort of like what you were talking about,
this people that have this simplistic idea that all you have to do is get Donald
Trump high on dmt and he's gonna see the light.
That's not necessarily the case.
Not necessarily the case.
I think it would be wasted on him.
I think we would have to do at least
at least an indwelling catheter may be two or three hours of continuous dmt.
Fusion.
Sorry,
wrong,
wrong term.
Why intravenous,
but it's very,
very freudian decided to go through his dick.
That is hilarious.
No,
we'll.
We'll go through the vein.
No,
man.
I think he might have nailed it the first time.
Might be the way to get it.
Maybe the way to get it to them in some perfect Russian robot fuck doll who just
locks them up and you know.
Right when he gets inside.
There you go.
She gets them in full guard.
Locks in place and catheter delivery.
Wow.
Yeah.
Maybe they can program it like,
like Dmt,
like little nanobots that go right through the hole,
right through the penis hole right into the system.
They just run out of her right in there and he's,
he just takes off.
But again,
there has to be something there.
Somebody animated that have an effect.
Please.
So many anime.
I know there's somebody out there that wants to do it.
The Internet is sort of exposed all this stuff.
So that was the end of it.
That literal use,
the end design and tall.
And how much has it dropped off since then?
Well,
it's been estimated by people who would know that there's maybe 20,000
scientologists right now.
What was it at its peak?
I think it was in the early nineties.
You bought 100,000.
Wow.
Yeah,
20,000.
That's like a,
a good Louis ck concert.
Well,
the thing is
most people I get that international base are people who have been around for
25,
30,
35,
40 years.
And you think,
okay,
how could you live this way?
Look,
most people are not going to do what I do.
I was 76 one 76 years old when I left.
Okay.
And you were 75 when they give you 75 gifts.
So you like this?
Not Enough.
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
I need.
No,
you mean not enough gifts to get in 76.
Right.
You got.
Listen,
I
actually,
I'll tell you something that happened and I brought this just to show you and
have a little.
What is that?
Kindle.
Okay.
Are you allowed to have those in there?
No.
Really.
You can't have a kindle and I didn't know why.
I didn't know why.
What happened is this.
David gave me this Kendall
and the security guards were doing.
They're not trying to get it away from me,
but they wouldn't come in strong army because David is the man.
So David gave it to you in the security guards are trying to take it away from
you.
Why?
Okay.
I didn't know.
Did you tell them?
It was loaded up with l Ron Hubbard books where it was.
It was his fiction books that he put in your field earth?
No,
not battlefield or northern machinery,
but the other earlier fiction,
which I thought was pretty interesting,
but anyway,
they're trying to get the says,
Hey,
fuck you man.
They gave me,
this is mine,
you know.
Oh,
okay.
Ron Did back off.
Now one day I'm reading something and there's a feature on here where you see
this is the camera on that now?
Yeah.
Okay.
You see this little
switch here that goes this way,
this way up.
Down and in.
So if you got a word that you'd like to look up and get the meaning of,
you'd go to the library or not.
The library.
The dictionary,
and you'd select the award and pressure to the right and it would say search
store.
I accidentally held it a little bit too long and it went right past search store
to google.
I was on the Internet with
no filter.
It is a crazy little machines.
It's a big ass,
but you're not buying that shit.
Eddie nearly killed.
It looks like an explosion.
It's an a bomb
bomb.
Bomb went off.
That's the only song I know.
It's the biggest bomb that ever has been dropped in war outside of a nuclear
bomb.
Well you don't believe non nuclear is
crazy.
I am.
Tell me.
I'm trying to figure out what's the end goal.
Why are they showing us this?
That's what I'm thinking.
That's how crazy I am.
I'm fucking so anything when it becomes,
when it comes to military shit that's blasted on the history channel or CNN,
I'm automatically.
What's their angle?
I don't.
Let me ask you this.
Have a conversation.
You need to have crazy dinosaurs.
I'm crazy.
Dinosaurs are real or not.
I don't trust that shit.
You don't just do that.
I love that triceratops because everybody loves when the triceratops,
tyrannosaurus rex.
Everybody's rooting for the triceratops.
If you ruined for the tyrannosaurus rex in that epic battle Douche bag.
Right?
You're right.
So you did those.
We'll do.
What about woolly mammoth?
Um,
I,
I would say a yes.
Oh,
you got to fucking elephant.
You know what I mean?
It's the fucking elephant.
Tyranosaurs rex is a new one where they're going to bring it back.
Source is a giant kangaroo.
That's what it is.
That's my guess.
It looks exactly the same.
It's kind of tail hops around on two legs.
Tyriana.
That's a fucking.
They found a giant kangaroo.
And when they figured it out,
they go,
dude,
it's a kangaroo with a guy like
Josh steps.
Today's sad day for the last bill o'reilly.
Oh,
I'm moaning at you.
Morning Joe.
I feel like I should be,
but I'm not one ton of loot.
What's that?
I said he made a ton of loot.
I mean since [inaudible] 96 when Fox News launched and he was like the big.
I'm just making it up that that's when Fox News launched.
Let's check out Jamie,
is that when Fox News launched 96 truck,
another trick,
he has pulled in so much money for that network and for himself.
He was one of the bunch.
Was the main guy really?
He really was the main guy in broadcasting.
They're going to find another old to fill a spot.
They're going to have to know.
That's what people look at that October seventh,
19,
96.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you're welcome.
America.
You'll were that.
He was on like hard copy or something like that,
right?
I don't even know.
I was too young,
but I wasn't even here in the states.
I was a school child in Australia,
little child.
I don't remember him from anything else.
I just remember him being on o'reilly and watching it and going,
what is like that longing for in the Stall Gia thing?
You know,
you see an older gentleman in a tie who just said,
well that's the way it is.
The tide goes in,
tide goes out.
Can you explain it?
Like,
what in the fuck is this guy doing?
That was when he was talking.
He was talking to an atheist resume.
Who was he?
Was it?
Oh,
I don't remember who was like,
maybe it was ricky Gervais' or some.
I can't remember,
but he was saying,
well maybe it was sam.
Could it have been saying?
I don't know who it was.
Someone was saying like I was saying what he was like.
Bill was like,
I've got the absolute number one reason why you have to believe in God because
tide goes in.
Tide goes out.
Always been that way.
Always will be that way goes round or it spins around.
How do you explain that?
If not,
God?
It was just super obvious that he was pandering because the guy went to fucking
Harvard.
Okay.
Bill O'reilly's not a dope.
He might be a Douche bag,
but he's not a dope.
He's,
I think religion makes people dopey and they'd done that don't even know about.
I don't even think he's religious.
I think he's barely religious.
I think he's religious enough to get by with the job.
I think he's innocent.
He has been in some 100 percent because I think he's one of the.
Look,
I don't watch the show a lot,
so I'm not sure,
but I,
he's always struck me as one of the more straight shooters.
I think he is.
He's smart,
but not wise.
Yes.
Uh,
you know,
he feels what he feels in his gut is more important than what the data tells
him.
And I think he falls for a bunch of fallacies that a lot of people fall for,
especially if they're religious,
like the idea that there was a certain order to the cosmos and how could we all
have come about?
How could this whole thing around us exist with all these butterflies and the
moon and the tide comes in and the tide goes out and says,
he's me and Joe,
these spiritual creatures,
these beings sitting opposite each other on a,
at a table in Los Angeles right now.
Some people just find that to inexplicably to explain without a diety,
so they're like,
all right,
there must have been a big guy who did it.
Yeah.